okay first of all sorry for taking so
long was I've been sick as a dog
there was like no way I was like we
could have recorded like hello welcome
to the calm happy lost a little bit
awesome you totally should have done
that and he also did get a chance to see
Thor - so what I like of something
driving on that coming up but we're not
talking about that we are talking about
Legend of Korra the guide and where was
this Korra all along not only this Korra
but everything know that like the tents
and stuff has always been good but isn't
me or did this one feel like how about
you by cat this feeling like the
original last airbender show like just
something about the pacing of it
something about the kind ways I'm pretty
bad about it was really bad but keep in
mind you were like and about the first
season of corn I really liked the first
I mean like to me it's reminding me more
of the first season of Korra for me a
little bit of the first season is there
is you know very dark I think he always
said it's very much so like this is the
dark night version of light yeah it's
fine to be thriller yeah which is fine
but it is nice to also see sort of in
the in this world they've done to have
something that really star called back
to those roots it just it felt like a
warm episode it felt like you got the
family they're reunited again they're
all on this mission you still have this
coming to grips with the daughter
they're like she can see the spirits
intense and coming with to terms with
the fact that he cannot guide her to the
spirit world something he's always
wanted to do so even though he was like
eggs favorite apparently he still
couldn't come through on this it's just
there's a lot going on and it's all very
genuine it feels really it just it's a
good episode
and yes Korra actually you know of
course you apologize it yeah big shock
like when they reunite it's like yeah I
didn't see us come in but at the same
time it's it's very hard film and it's
it's very nice and she's using her head
she's like maybe we should use the
youngest daughter maybe we should do
that me it's well and there's a nice
role reversal where
Tenzin's the stubborn one who's he know
that fells my biggest fear is that when
they were doing the spiritual thing
she's gonna be like I'm not feeling it
gosh darn it I was like I I didn't wanna
do that but yes I like this next around
like he's the one they can't get in
there and that he's making up excuses
like I think there's some moment where
it's just like well then so be it we
will go to the spirit world now is this
like finally yeah like well okay now for
a show called the spirit world I'm like
oh my god there's been so little time
dealing with the spirit world here well
and here's the interesting thing I
noticed with this episode - so many good
interesting things happen this episode
now seen to myself like when they spread
this out you have the girls see oh you
know read my mind know what you see the
girl sees the statue and that only now
do you see why could you add that
throughout the series have this mission
we've built he's like and when did you
see this and she's like I just like
shout it out a million episodes ago okay
like why couldn't they have this go
throughout the series you know or okay
we find on this one that Tarla 2.0 it
now is in cahoots with whatever the bad
spirit was the one from like eons ago of
vaatu yeah okay how much of a bigger
shock would this be if we started out
earlier with the backstory of the avatar
and then only now so I but when it's
just one episode or two episodes later
it's like oh well I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna say this Christ only knows I'm
gonna have fanboys knocking on my door
with a gun pointed to my head but the
story itself overall is okay I've had
some issues with the story going but the
story itself the the actual groundwork
the pieces are okay the actual
storytelling yeah has been sloppy this
has been sloppy sloppy sloppy
storytelling until just a couple
episodes the the episode with the
original avatar yeah here's another
great idea why not
tell both stories at the same time the
story of core going through this thing
and then also maybe she's getting
flashes cuz that'll be awesome yes
like what
doing with her remembering what happened
with a remember yeah you know and like
when they do that showing that story
slowly progressed over to is I'm with
you now that I see what they're doing
with it's like it's not a bad story the
execution of it and the policing and the
tiling is not well I'm so torn because
I'm so appreciative of this episode in
the previous episode they're both so
good but at the same time as much as I'm
like oh these are really good episodes
and this is really good now I'm just
kind of like it just drives how bad
those first few episodes really were in
trying to get their point across and
telling a coherent story because I'm
like there was so it felt like it was so
much filler and so meandering and even
if you're like well today it wasn't
filler because this it's still you could
pace it out you could have paced it
better and written it better and put it
together in a more cohesive way and it's
just hammering in how sloppy it was
those first few episodes I'm like here
now they have this like this pinpoint
focus it's like now they've got it yeah
we got going there but all the setup was
necessary I'm like man I feel like I
could have gone through that setup and
pretty much cut out two whole episode
yeah like I said at the very least you
could have spread out this good stuff
with the spirit again it's called
spirits with the rest of the Emmis I
mean for a while was the all Varrick ma
Co nuktuk story yeah you are kind of
stuff which is fine but it's like it's
called spirits it's supposed to be out
of the spiritual world and it's just so
chopped up and I think part of good
storytelling is that you do sort of want
to be balanced out and and you know
spread throughout the whole thing so
it's I mean when we finally get to the
spirit stuff it's great heck even maybe
some of the stuff with you know with the
whole crime story and everything could
have been good if it was paced out there
I don't know what to deal it like I know
looking at a lot of the credits it seems
like the original creators did not have
writing duties yeah that that's why
many episodes I think they had the
previous episode with the original
avatar I think that's one god whoo you
like which would make everyone see that
because it was a really good episode but
I that's almost what it feels like like
it's like people who've been explained
to what Korra and avatar is about trying
to cough up a script and I think this
was a different writer for biz I don't
think this is one of the original
creators I died only glanced at the
credits quickly before we turn the
camera on but if that's the case this
guy whoever this was actually got it
well I mean we we don't know for sure it
looks like maybe we saw in the Kratz I
mean we should say if we don't yeah we
should probably check again yeah but but
whoever was writing is if this is what
the original creators or whatever it did
this time it's like they got it like
this feels right yeah what what it
whatever whoever whatever they did with
this episode they needed it before and
hopefully it'll keep going in the future
it looks like it's gonna keep going cuz
I mean now they're entering the spirit
world and it's yes now that being said
can we address a little bit of dumb cuz
it's still a little bit of dumb please
wait we're critics are over love to do
the fact that they're setting up a love
triangle again between Korra and Asami
kill me now I mean no my favorite is
when she's apparently for I hate framed
stories - you know what did you show
what did you show that is like yeah he's
been using you the whole time but don't
you believe it rose just worship rose
look we got here love joined on the
steve-o it's like oh yeah you know again
Lin beifong I don't know what stupid
pill medication she's on but it's like
cut back your dose this used to be so
beautiful man used to be so beautiful
that's like I'm obviously in the pockets
of these two crooked cops yes Starsky
and Hutch
I you know maybe would be a little more
believable if they didn't draw them as
such obvious crooked calves but they
really look like something out of
Springfield yeah at the very least like
their dumb cop take them away toys what
you see to do is you can change yeah I
mean that stuff is just kind and yeah
the whole idea behind the love
chocolates like you guys are dating
again I'm like I'm okay with them it's
like but you just left core a week ago
I'm like yeah and I was like she kicked
my desk halfway across my workplace and
was just being really obnoxious to me
but yeah I'm using to help that that's
the thing that's the thing about me is
that like the the bringing back the love
triangle just reminds you again of how
obnoxious core has been in the past
episode it's and it's like I'm just now
getting used to my selectable Cora from
a writing perspective I don't get that
like I'm hoping they're just not gonna
do anything with it I hope it just dies
almost instantly and I'm at a point
where I so do not want to deal with it
that if he goes back to core 5 he goes
back to Cora but just make it
instantaneous like if Fiesta Sheva saw
me off a cliff cuz I'm like I'm not
sitting through 12 episodes or however
many we're gonna go through all right
okay how about this how about this he he
decides to go with Asami and Cora
fucking understands she's like you know
what I understand we kill if that's the
case I don't know III doubt it but it's
like one not be like she's really come
to her own it's like one that beat with
this unbelievable progression I'm just
like here like looking at this and I'm
like I'm almost convinced that whoever
is doing this show this season did not
watch season one cuz I'm like we did
this we were there this was resolved and
now you're doing it again
you know Cassie again it feels a little
bit kinda like fan fiction where it's
like well we got the feel and we know
what it's like so we're just gonna catch
it again you know so it's like cuz it's
not like it's totally for and it's like
no and they've added a lot of cool stuff
but you're right with the Korra
character it's just sort of like well
we've seen those and if this worked the
first times and that's my understanding
of it now that's but what's not dumb is
yeah Asami kind of falls for Varrick you
know
verax trick or whatever and it may be a
little dumb that she does
leave ma Co right away because when ma
can make it up but did you notice her
reaction because that was not dumb
if in Monaco's reaction she's like are
you okay
you stressed like yeah is everything all
right cuz I'm just kind of worried cuz
like yeah this sounds kind of weird like
you just saved my company and if that
were Cora he would be in like some sort
of waterbending tornado
yeah it's halfway across the planet for
suggesting something like that again
that's why I hate this low track it just
reminds me what up Carrie and the funny
of the funny thing is is like his
reactions just so like what what this is
like yeah I'm not used to my girlfriend
you know treating me with respect
they're not like trying to kick my ass
and just going off on me no I'm gonna
say right now because we haven't seen we
know it's a week behind and this will
probably put together over two videos
but we haven't seen the next episode yet
I'm just gonna put in my bid now it may
not my bid but I think Varrick is sort
of talking in a way because he is so
eccentric it's so strange I think it's
totally possible that there may be
playing that actually it's possible he's
not behind it that it sounds like he's
being obvious hits but he's just so
benign and eccentric and crazy you're
gonna try to fool us
yeah my original guesses are maybe it
just along to be the bad guy
my original guest who said he was crazy
as a fox at half his craziness is
actually a put-on yeah I don't know it's
the only thing I will say to this shows
advantage and that beam so meandering
and just kind of throwing everything out
there early on that I am kind of like
almost in the position of is like I
don't know exactly where they're going
with this because it's really just been
like sort of a crapshoot of like what
hmm
it's like somebody yeah but I don't know
I mean I even if Varrick is the bad guy
I'm like oh that's still kind of
interesting it's given the characters no
I know I just I'll tell you what it
keeps coming back to it when I walk
though I start to fall asleep like I
just he's just not that compelling to me
oh well you got to move a to Nick to or
whatever he's more like compelling as a
bad guy he quiet such a jazz stuck in
his choice I mean I I mean we
a little bit with him like you know like
the Sun gets injured and you know it's
like it's not important it's like okay
well now the siblings are gonna seem
they're obviously gonna turn and fight
against him oh yeah but and yeah like I
said it's just our luck to point out the
lock isn't his name I know I know we
were coming to this conclusion like okay
here's the pattern if lock is in your
name particularly at the end you're bad
don't trust him just don't trust him no
I like the designed to with vaatu stuck
in the tree but the tree is shaped in
such a way that looks like this is giant
I in the tree I can peek at like a
little eye of Sauron thing yeah so now
most things in this episode oh and the
Wuzzles we've decided the spirits like
it took us a while yeah they're all in a
connection you never made this
connection to frickin Wuzzles like these
kids what will get it got 80s kids if
you grew up any of these like we did you
understand but Nickelodeon why are you
not marketing these things I'm sorry god
i funny
instant toy I mean market these things
then reinvest in more avatar you don't
need to play games with us anymore
you'll have enough money and be like I
don't care if it's successful or not we
made a ship to the money on the
Dragonfly bunny it's more possibly a
platypus bunny you're welcome only
saying bad six nipples yeah he did
design it by the way so I said here's
what it looks like and then he put that
again like wow then I remember I just
turned you like when you gave me the
description that was like fuck you okay
so the Dragonfly buddies are probably
more marketable but we're just saying
there's a free one in there if you want
to take advantage yeah that dude was
like there my spirit friends that is
kind of thinking that kind of game
it's all of the like the pastels a
little flying that's not like your
Dinklage from Narnia to just like do you
see them
no yeah so no I I really like this
episode I wish it was spread out over
others but it's still really solid and
really good and I can't wait to see the
next one we're back in action